welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com
farronbalancedandyoutube.com the ring of
fire and of course every week i host the
ring of fire podcast go to
rofpodcast.com
well we've got more coveted news to talk
about
and it actually calls back to a story we
talked about yesterday as you'll recall
we showed the clip of donald trump and
bill o'reilly their little rewrite
history tour
where donald trump sheepishly admitted
that he had in fact gotten the coveted
booster
the crowd booed him they did not want to
hear that
and then
bill o'reilly this week does an
interview with dan abrams on news nation
and o'reilly admits
to abrams that he had to console trump
after that crowd booed him after the
event of course they weren't on stage
when the
you know
make him feel better part took place
so here's what o'reilly said
i told him that today he called me
he was hurt by their reaction i said
this is good for you this is good that
people see another side of you not a
political side you told the truth you
believe in the facts your administration
did it and you should take credit for it
because it did save i don't know
hundreds of thousands of lives
so i'm just picturing this scenario in
my head right
because this wasn't even like backstage
after the event that o'reilly had to go
up to and be like hey bud you okay no
this was like the next day
trump calls him
and harald he's probably like oh god
yeah
i'm hello so sad they they were so mean
to me
yeah bud um listen hey
sometimes it's okay sometimes it happens
now listen as i said yesterday i'm
actually okay with donald trump claiming
he created the vaccines whatever it
takes to get these people vaccinated at
this point right
but at the same time
you did this
i mean you you were the only one who
didn't appear in that you know psa with
some of the other former presidents who
encourage people to get vaccinated
you've openly expressed your disdain
for wearing masks like you're literally
encouraging your followers to not
protect themselves
even in your little diatribe that we
talked about you still said if you don't
want to get it don't get it no mandates
no mandates
you're driving them
to this
so you don't get to be upset
when
your little frankenstein's monster
turns on its creator
and that is exactly what happened here
the the cue people out there
they're now confused and
a little angry because they don't know
how to feel about trump because suddenly
he's he's promoting the vaccine so rest
assured we're going to end up with a new
conspiracy theory in the next couple
days as to why trump really
claimed to have been boosted
so i i guarantee you that's on the
horizon so be on the lookout for that
but again
you made this possible
by downplaying the pandemic
by suggesting it was overblown by
repeatedly telling us last year that oh
it's going to be gone soon oh
everything's going to be fine
and then of course not encouraging
people to get vaccinated hiding your own
vaccination status from people
that drives them
to these horrible horrible decisions
and of course contributed
to their anti-vaxx ideology
believe it or not that was not even the
weirdest thing that o'reilly said
during that interview with dan abrams
he goes on to say
i'm trying to tell president trump run
on your record
he's going to run again all right
so bill o'reilly who clearly is in close
contact with donald trump has spent
several weeks with him has spent other
time with him throughout this year tells
us that without a doubt
donald trump is running for president in
2024
so that's something we also have to deal
with something that also has to be
addressed
but
to his statement run on your record what
record is that
400 000 dead americans and a pandemic
that you pretended wasn't a big deal
a trade war with china
that you had no idea what the end goal
was you just started it because you were
i don't know feeling a little weird that
day
or is it your border wall
that's sitting down there literally
falling apart washing away and rusting
this is about the only three things oh
i'm sorry tax cuts
you also cut taxes for the wealthy and
screwed over working class people by
taking away some of our deductions
what else i mean for real what else was
donald trump's record here
so bill when you tell him run on your
record
you got to be a little more specific
than that because there's only a handful
of things the guy did and all of them
are bad
right there's no good thing
when you look at it from a purely
nonpartisan political
analysis
what good thing happened during the
trump administration are there truly any
people in this country who can look at
that and say oh my life is better off
today
at the end of his administration than it
was at the beginning he did something
that made me better of course
the top 10 percent of income earners
sure they can say that 100 percent
but the rest of the country no we can't
say that
there was either no change or it got
worse and of course with the pandemic it
got worse for everybody
except the
billionaires so i don't know that
encouraging him to run on his record is
the smartest thing
unless of course you want him to lose
which i do so yes please run on your
record and remind people how horrible
those four years were
now some people are probably thinking no
fear and he did have an accomplishment
he packed the courts with republican
hacks and i'm going to counter you on
that and say that was not necessarily
trump that was mitch mcconnell that
would have happened under any republican
president
mitch mcconnell would have made that
happen so no i do not count that as a
trump thing i count that as a mcconnell
thing
and i know trump would probably be
furious to hear people say that
but hey that's the reality under which
we live today
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you i use atlasvpn to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
tech platforms online marketers even
governments and atlas vpn keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information if i turn on atlas vpn
before logging into netflix hulu or
amazon i can access streaming content
from other countries i can even watch
stuff from argentina like soccer i use
atlas vpn on all of my devices you
install it you turn it on once and then
you just forget about it and enjoy your
privacy you can read online about why
vpns are so important to use every day
really something you should have and
atlas vpn is having a huge sale giving
you 86 off comes out to like a dollar 39
a month for a subscription plus you'll
get three months free just go to atlas v
dot pn slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below